[Musique]
bonsoir à tous c'est un grand honneur
pour moi d'être parmi vous ce soir et
d'avoir l'opportunité de vous expliquer
pourquoi l'innovation et les nouvelles
technologies sont la clé pour un futur
plus équitable et respectueux mais avant
tout je vais me présenter je m'appelle
Alessia zeoli j'ai 26 ans je suis
italobelge et comme l'a dit Théo ça fait
maintenant trois ans que je vis au
Mexique
je parle cadres français italien
espagnol et anglais et c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui m'a permis de devenir ingénieur
linguistique d'ailleurs petite question
qui sait ce qu'est un ingénieur
linguistique parmi vous
ça tombe bien moi non plus je savais pas
vend d'être engagé
un ingénieur linguistique travail à la
croisée des domaines de la linguistique
de la technologie et de l'intelligence
artificielle
notre travail consiste à concevoir et
développer des programmes et des
applications qui traitent les langues
humaines exemple
j'imagine que la plupart d'entre vous
doit avoir ce petit appareil connecté à
la maison auquel on donne des commandes
avec le pouvoir de notre voix pour
allumer ou éteindre des lumières ou pour
mettre de la musique à tout moment et
bien c'est nous qui sommes derrière tout
ça
c'est drôle parce que de base j'ai pas
du tout étudié ni ingénierie ni
programmation j'ai étudié marketing en
Belgique
et après mes études j'ai décidé de
prendre une année sabbatique afin de
voyager en Amérique latine pour faire le
bien car j'ai toujours été très sensible
vis-à-vis des problématiques sociaux
environnementales
j'ai donc commencé mon voyage
par la Bolivie
sauf que je suis arrivée là-bas deux
jours seulement après qu'une mutinerie
nationale et commencer pour remplacer le
dictateur Evo Morales qui gouvernait à
ce moment là
tout le pays était mobilisé
je me suis donc retrouvée en pleine
révolution politique et sociale à me
battre aux côtés des Boliviens pour
faire respecter leurs droits et je peux
vous dire que cette expérience a
complètement changé ma vie
33 jours d'inactivité sociale et de
manifestations
et après ces 33 jours le dictateur a
enfin renoncé et c'était donc une
victoire
cette expérience a réveillé l'esprit
révolutionnaire qui était en moi
et m'a permis m'a permis de voir que
l'expression l'union fait la force
prenait tout son sens
après la Bolivie
j'ai décidé de continuer d'explorer
parce que je j'étais pleine d'espoir et
j'avais envie de changer le monde
mais je me sentais aussi un peu perdue
parce que je savais pas par où commencer
du coup
un ami un an après m'a invité à un
événement crypto à Mexico City
et ça changeait ma vie car j'ai
découvert
un univers totalement différent de ce
que je m'attendais parce qu'à l'époque
l'idée que j'avais des cryptos c'est que
c'est un milieu très spéculatif que
c'est du trading et que c'est rempli
d'arnaque
du coup
ce jour là j'ai découvert qu'en réalité
les fondements de la blockchain c'est la
décentralisation
la transparence
et la confiance
après avoir assisté à cet événement j'ai
commencé à lire tous les événements et à
côtoyer les professionnels les experts à
étudier à m'informer sur ce sujet si
passionnant
et il y a un an avec mon meilleur ami et
Associés Raphaël nous avons créé crypto
nautique qui est un incubateur de
projets web 3 spécialisé dans la
création et le développement de projet
avec un grand impact social
crypto nautique se divise en trois
parties il y a la partie de l'incubateur
où nous accompagnons les personnes dans
le développement de leur projet du début
jusqu'à la fin
il y a la partie de consulting où nous
aidons les entreprises dans leur
transition vers la blockchain pour
apporter des solutions à leur business
et la partie la plus importante
l'éducation pour que plus de personnes
sachent de quoi il s'agit réellement et
à quoi ça sert surtout
le premier projet que nous avons
développé en tant que crypto nautique
ces crypto nautiques art collectives car
l'art nous tient énormément à coeur et
nous avons énormément d'amis artistes
d'ailleurs et nous voyons à quel point
il était difficile de percer ou de vivre
de sa passion et de son talent
nous avons donc commencé à créer et
organiser des événements à Mexico City
qui mélange l'art et les nouvelles
technologies donc pourquoi les nouvelles
technologies parce que nous avons des
oculus dans lequel vous pouvez explorer
le métaver et créer
mais ça mélange aussi l'art physique
donc toutes les personnes peuvent
participer et ajouter une touche
créative à ses œuvres d'art et ça
réveille d'ailleurs l'artiste qui est en
nous c'est la meilleure façon de
d'apprendre
maintenant je vais vous présenter trois
projets que nous accompagnons qui ont un
grand grand impact social qui vont
probablement changer le monde j'espère
le premier projet s'appelle Eco box
ce petit appareil ou machine que vous
voyez là sert à recevoir des bouteilles
en plastique et des canettes usagées
en gros ce que vous devez faire c'est
juste les introduire à l'intérieur et
grâce à la technologie blockchain ça
nous permet de tracer ces déchets
jusqu'au centre de recyclage et ça nous
évite donc une surproduction et une
contamination environnementale et
surtout un coût pour les fabricants
aussi car ils peuvent récupérer
directement les mêmes produits et en
plus ça permet aux utilisateurs de
recevoir des avantages exclusifs comme
des bons d'achat ou des coupons qui
peuvent utiliser dans les supermarchés
le deuxième projet s'appelle motus Dao
c'est une plateforme de soins de santé
car actuellement il y a énormément de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à des
soins de santé de qualité due au manque
de ressources ou à leur localisation
géographique
et le troisième projet c'est péanto une
plateforme d'identité digitale qui
perfait qui permet de faciliter et
automatiser les procédures
gouvernementales et bancaires afin de ne
plus utiliser nos cartes d'identité
physique mais d'utiliser uniquement nos
données biométriques et rassurez-vous
toutes ces données sont les vôtres
comme vous avez pu le voir la
technologie a le pouvoir de transformer
et révolutionner les secteurs d'activité
et les industries
bien souvent on pense que pour faire
partie de cet écosystème il faut être
ingénieur ou trader ou informaticien ou
développeurs et bien pas du tout tout le
monde peut apporter son savoir-faire et
changer le monde pour créer un meilleur
futur
et d'ailleurs si vous aussi vous avez
envie de changer les choses mais vous ne
savez pas comment faire vous savez vers
qui vous tourner
pour conclure
j'aimerais citer Léon trosky qui a dit
un jour
la vie est belle que les générations
futures la délivre du mal de
l'oppression et de la violence et
qu'elles en profitent pleinement alors
vous en dites quoi on le tente
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]